Caption: this one is by Melissa Houghton and it's
Caption: called leadership through self-awareness
Caption: so a little bit about Melissa Melissa
Caption: Houghton is a lead software engineer at
Caption: azenix and a Microsoft MVP in developer
Caption: Technologies
Caption: her work is focused on application
Caption: development using angular.net and azure
Caption: but she has a wide variety of skills and
Caption: is always open to learning new things an
Caption: advocate for women in Tech with a
Caption: passion for leadership technology and
Caption: giving back to the community
Caption: she frequent she frequents Tech events
Caption: is an International Conference speaker
Caption: and organizer of DDD Melbourne
Caption: conference
Caption: melb.net Meetup and Microsoft Au new
Caption: breakpoint community
Caption: originally from California Melissa loves
Caption: to travel and now lives in Melbourne
Caption: Australia
Caption: thanks Melissa
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: become a great leader by understanding
Caption: yourself
Caption: a leader is not determined by someone's
Caption: title but by their influence over others
Caption: and the people around them anyone can be
Caption: a leader but first you need to have the
Caption: right skills and a key skill to becoming
Caption: a great leader is understanding ourself
Caption: so through this talk I will dive into
Caption: leadership through self-awareness and
Caption: how building up your skills in
Caption: self-awareness can help you become a
Caption: better leader
Caption: because a leader is not just somebody
Caption: who's out at the front it's somebody who
Caption: has followers and through self-awareness
Caption: not only will you become a better leader
Caption: but so will those around you and so will
Caption: your organization and your team
Caption: so first I'd like to give a big shout
Caption: out to all of the the organizers for DDD
Caption: Perth I used to live here in Perth
Caption: myself and helped organize a DDD for a
Caption: couple years over in Perth and now I
Caption: help with the one in Melbourne and
Caption: there's a ton of work that goes into an
Caption: event like this and also a massive shout
Caption: out to all of our sponsors because
Caption: without them this wouldn't be able to
Caption: happen
Caption: so as I mentioned my name is Melissa
Caption: Houghton and I'm the lead software
Caption: engineer and also now a developer
Caption: relations at a zenix and at zenix is
Caption: part of mantle group who are one of the
Caption: sponsors here today and I'm also a
Caption: Microsoft MVP in developer Technologies
Caption: I try to be pretty active on Twitter and
Caption: if you are on Twitter please follow me
Caption: and take photos of my talk today and
Caption: share along your your thoughts as I'm
Caption: going
Caption: so this talk is all about leadership
Caption: through self-awareness and that concept
Caption: is not a unique one
Caption: and I got the idea for this talk through
Caption: all the different leadership training
Caption: courses I've done and I also did a lot
Caption: of research on the topic there's tons of
Caption: studies that have been published about
Caption: this but really the idea for the talk
Caption: came through a leadership camp that I
Caption: attended through Rotary Club and then I
Caption: went on to be a camp counselor for
Caption: this Camp was called rila which stands
Caption: for rotary youth leadership awards and
Caption: the whole Camp was centered around
Caption: building up your self-awareness and how
Caption: that can help you to become a better
Caption: leader
Caption: so I was in this campus also focused on
Caption: young adults age 18 to 28 so I was lucky
Caption: enough to be able to attend a few years
Caption: ago and then go on to council and help
Caption: share those skills with other people as
Caption: well and I'm not trying to retrofit the
Caption: camp into this talk but that idea of
Caption: becoming a great leader by understanding
Caption: yourself is one that has always stuck
Caption: with me so I decided to put together
Caption: this talk for all of you
Caption: so what is leadership leadership has
Caption: many definitions
Caption: I looked up the definition and it says
Caption: it's the action of leading a group of
Caption: people or an organization
Caption: I didn't find that entirely helpful so I
Caption: went on to then look up the definition
Caption: of Fleet
Caption: and this said it's the initiative and
Caption: inaction an example for others to follow
Caption: up so if we put that together we can say
Caption: that leadership is the action of taking
Caption: the initiative and setting an example
Caption: for other people to then follow
Caption: and I like this definition because to me
Caption: a leader is somebody who has followers
Caption: the followers are what make you a leader
Caption: it's not someone who necessarily has it
Caption: in their title or is that at the top of
Caption: the ladder in a corporate organization
Caption: is the person who is out there making a
Caption: difference who is checking on those
Caption: teammates who might be struggling a
Caption: little bit having support being a role
Caption: model and setting an example really
Caption: being a true influence for others around
Caption: them
Caption: it can be anyone at any level that they
Caption: can have any sort of type of background
Caption: personality be any type of person they
Caption: could be you
Caption: a leader is someone who is out at the
Caption: front being the center for everyone else
Caption: to see how they can really truly be a
Caption: great leader in helping other people
Caption: around them be the best versions of
Caption: themselves
Caption: and with the right skills and attitude
Caption: and approach to working with others
Caption: people will naturally follow you so what
Caption: makes a good leader I'd like to hear
Caption: from some people in the audience what do
Caption: you think makes the good leader
Caption: just shout it out if
Caption: any thoughts empathy empathy yeah that's
Caption: a great one
Caption: trust yes
Caption: respect definitely
Caption: listening yes
Caption: understanding yeah
Caption: yeah all of these traits are definitely
Caption: things that we we really want to see in
Caption: leaders we want to be able to have them
Caption: empathize with us listen to our concerns
Caption: to really support us as we're doing
Caption: things and understand when we're going
Caption: through maybe difficult situations
Caption: so they're the people who are you know
Caption: supporting us through those processes
Caption: um helping us when there might be maybe
Caption: those little tasks on the side that may
Caption: have been forgotten to help the team
Caption: reach the goal
Caption: and it doesn't always have to be just
Caption: one leader a lot of situations there's
Caption: leaders in different aspects that all
Caption: work together to help the team achieve
Caption: the end goal think about in a game of
Caption: basketball you have the coach you might
Caption: have the the team captain or you have
Caption: someone who's setting up the play who's
Caption: making the assist and then the person
Caption: who's shooting the hoop in the end
Caption: all of them had their own part to play
Caption: in reaching that outcome and they were
Caption: all leaders in their own right they took
Caption: that initiative and they supported one
Caption: another to help achieve success
Caption: so in the words of Bill Gates as we look
Caption: ahead into the next Century leaders will
Caption: be those who Empower others
Caption: so how do we Empower others
Caption: how do we become that person that other
Caption: people want to follow
Caption: and it really can come down to
Caption: understanding of ourselves before we can
Caption: look at taking care of those around us
Caption: and really influencing them we first
Caption: have to understand ourselves and our own
Caption: actions and how we approach different
Caption: situations
Caption: self-awareness does not equate to
Caption: leadership but it is a fundamental skill
Caption: that can really help you to be a great
Caption: leader
Caption: and all those traits that we mentioned
Caption: empathy listening active communication
Caption: being authentic and supporting those
Caption: around you really empowering others
Caption: it first starts with understanding
Caption: yourself
Caption: so self-awareness well this is the act
Caption: of being aware of yourself
Caption: it's all about being aware of your
Caption: emotions your personality how you react
Caption: in different situations and how all
Caption: those things are perceived by others
Caption: your strengths and weaknesses the skills
Caption: that you have that you need to continue
Caption: to to work on or the ones that you're
Caption: really great at and you can really
Caption: harness and use
Caption: people are not born completely
Caption: self-aware but as an infant as a baby we
Caption: do start to develop self-awareness and
Caption: we can continue to build it throughout
Caption: our life
Caption: however research has shown that only 10
Caption: to 15 percent of people are what they
Caption: consider truly self-aware
Caption: but we can all work on our
Caption: self-awareness and continue to build it
Caption: the study of self-awareness that we know
Caption: it today began in 1972 with Shelley
Caption: Duvall and Robert Woodland
Caption: although the concept of self-awareness
Caption: is one that has been around for
Caption: centuries and people have been talking
Caption: and trying to understand self for a very
Caption: long time
Caption: but that theory from Shelley Duvall and
Caption: Robert Wickland proposed that at a given
Caption: moment people can focus attention on
Caption: their self or on the external
Caption: environment around them
Caption: and through their research they divided
Caption: self-awareness into two sub-categories
Caption: the first is your internal
Caption: self-awareness so this is the awareness
Caption: of your internal state of being and how
Caption: you are your emotions and how you're
Caption: reacting to things your natural
Caption: tendencies and generally we don't always
Caption: Focus internally or on ourselves but
Caption: there's certain situations that can
Caption: cause our attention to be drawn inward
Caption: take for a moment to take a deep breath
Caption: breathe into your nose
Caption: and out to your mouth
Caption: most of the time you don't really think
Caption: about how you're breathing but because I
Caption: drew your attention to it and you
Caption: actively took that deep breath in and
Caption: out you have become aware of your
Caption: breathing
Caption: so internal self-awareness is something
Caption: that happens privately something inside
Caption: our head of okay this is now how we're
Caption: breathing in and out
Caption: it's the type of awareness when you
Caption: become aware of some aspect of yourself
Caption: but in a way that no one else can see
Caption: because it's happening inside your mind
Caption: so it's an awareness of that internal
Caption: state
Caption: on the other hand is the external
Caption: self-awareness and what this means is
Caption: it's really our perceived awareness of
Caption: how others see us and it's only
Caption: perceived because we don't actually 100
Caption: know what other people are seeing in us
Caption: but we usually have some sort of idea or
Caption: maybe just a guess of what people are
Caption: seeing when maybe they're they're
Caption: watching us up on stage or we're
Caption: interacting with them in a certain
Caption: situations
Caption: for example here I am up here talking
Caption: and I can see you all looking at me and
Caption: I'm coming to some conclusions of what
Caption: you might be thinking
Caption: when we know that we're being watched
Caption: and evaluated we often try to act in
Caption: ways that we think are socially
Caption: acceptable
Caption: so you're in a situation with your
Caption: friends and someone says a joke that
Caption: might be a bit controversial you'll
Caption: probably look around to your friends to
Caption: see how they react before you react as
Caption: well so you want to make sure you fit
Caption: into those discolable norms and that's
Caption: an example of that external
Caption: self-awareness
Caption: so our external self-awareness is
Caption: usually influences or actions to be
Caption: related to society expectations where
Caption: our internal self-awareness is really
Caption: driven by our personal values and the
Caption: things that really mean most to us
Caption: internally
Caption: so Dr Tasha urch research self-awareness
Caption: in the context of leaders and
Caption: organizations and took the concept of
Caption: these internal and external and
Caption: categorized it into four separate
Caption: sub-archetypes of self-awareness
Caption: so on the bottom left corner we have
Caption: what are called Seekers these people
Caption: have the low internal and low external
Caption: so they don't really know too much about
Caption: themselves but they're open-minded and
Caption: they're they're open to learning new
Caption: things however they probably are getting
Caption: frustrated because they're not quite
Caption: sure what they value and they might not
Caption: understand what might be happening in
Caption: certain situations
Caption: next we have on the top left corner
Caption: those who have high internal and low
Caption: external
Caption: so these people are very clear on what
Caption: is really most important to them but
Caption: they might not be as aware of how their
Caption: actions and things that they're doing
Caption: are perceived by others and often
Caption: they're a bit close-minded and not open
Caption: to learning new things so that can harm
Caption: some of the relationships with people
Caption: in the bottom right corner we have
Caption: Pleasers these people are very highly
Caption: externally self-aware very aware of how
Caption: other people are perceiving them but
Caption: there have low internal self-awareness
Caption: so they're not as connected with what is
Caption: important to them and can feel
Caption: frustrated and that can hold them back
Caption: from getting success and fulfillment out
Caption: of what they're doing
Caption: and then the top right corner we have
Caption: those 10 to 15 of people who are truly
Caption: self-aware they have the high internal
Caption: and high external they really know
Caption: they're really in touch with who they
Caption: are and what they really value but
Caption: they're also very aware of those around
Caption: them and they're aware how they can
Caption: adapt to those current situations
Caption: now it's all a scale and a lot of it
Caption: depends on the situation all that but we
Caption: can work on building our different parts
Caption: of our self-awareness
Caption: so if we're looking though some of those
Caption: things that we're talking about the
Caption: self-awareness can be negative so if
Caption: we're focusing on the wrong things if
Caption: we're focusing term too much
Caption: internally we become maybe a bit
Caption: self-obsessed or you have trouble
Caption: understanding you know challenging
Caption: situations or things that might be out
Caption: of the norm for us
Caption: or if we're focusing too much externally
Caption: we can become quite anxious and always
Caption: aware of things that other people are
Caption: judging us or things that are negatively
Caption: happening so we have to be careful with
Caption: our our management of self-awareness
Caption: there's something that's called the
Caption: sadder but wiser paradox it says the
Caption: more we learn about ourselves it not
Caption: only makes us wiser but it can also make
Caption: us sadder
Caption: so we need to change how we address the
Caption: self-awareness and make sure we're not
Caption: mulling over the negative emotions and
Caption: instead reflecting objectively on the
Caption: positives
Caption: and we can do this by looking at the
Caption: questions that we're asking ourselves
Caption: we need to make sure our introspection
Caption: is on that positive side because if we
Caption: just start reflecting without the right
Caption: context it doesn't necessarily make us
Caption: happy it can make us worse because we're
Caption: focusing on the wrong things
Caption: and research has shown that we're not
Caption: able to pull up all of our unconscious
Caption: thoughts feelings and emotions and as
Caption: you learn to think what keynote this
Caption: morning as well your memory can be wrong
Caption: you can if you're looking at something
Caption: in a negative context and you're
Caption: remembering it you can end up having
Caption: these negative emotions connected to it
Caption: so we need to focus on moving forward
Caption: and instead of fixating on what happens
Caption: and we can do this by changing the
Caption: questions that we ask ourselves instead
Caption: of asking why we need to ask what
Caption: instead of saying why me why did this
Caption: happen look at what can I do to make it
Caption: better what can I change what can I
Caption: learn from this situation instead of
Caption: asking why am I so upset look at what
Caption: can make me happy what can I do to
Caption: change this situation focusing on
Caption: becoming that aware archetype working on
Caption: both the internal and external awareness
Caption: looking at what we're doing what we're
Caption: feeling and what are blind spots of what
Caption: we might not be aware be
Caption: and there's different tools that can
Caption: help us do this one of them is What's
Caption: called the Jahari window
Caption: so this is an activity uh where you get
Caption: a list of objectives that describe a
Caption: person so it can be something like
Caption: cheerful excited maybe reserved
Caption: something like that and you and a friend
Caption: go through the list and you Circle all
Caption: the adjectives that you think describe
Caption: yourself and your friend circles
Caption: adjectives that they think describes you
Caption: you then compare the two lists and the
Caption: adjectives that you both Circle are part
Caption: of your external self so this is the
Caption: things that you're reflecting to others
Caption: that they're aware of the things that
Caption: only use circled is that's your internal
Caption: self things that you find you are are
Caption: part of you but maybe other people don't
Caption: see that then your blind spots are
Caption: things that other people see in you but
Caption: you don't necessarily seeing yourself
Caption: so there's a few different tools and
Caption: techniques that you can do to help you
Caption: build up these skills
Caption: and if we continue to do that reflection
Caption: we can get the positives out of
Caption: self-awareness we can change those
Caption: questions from why to what and get an
Caption: increased understanding of our
Caption: self-development needs and the things
Caption: that we need to work on
Caption: and that around us can help us become
Caption: more proactive at work more
Caption: understanding of others more open-minded
Caption: and willing to take on the initiative
Caption: and be able to do well in challenging
Caption: situations or when faced with adversity
Caption: it can make us become more successful
Caption: and have more satisfied employees and
Caption: teammates around us and it can even lead
Caption: to organizations becoming more
Caption: successful and profitable as well
Caption: so to develop these self-awareness
Caption: skills there's other tools such as
Caption: understanding our internal self and our
Caption: personality
Caption: so our personality is usually determined
Caption: by our genetics but also environments
Caption: and situations and and how we're erased
Caption: and it's the characteristic patterns of
Caption: like how we think and behave and act in
Caption: certain situations and there's many
Caption: different tools that can help us to
Caption: understand a bit more about our
Caption: personality
Caption: a lot of these might not be 100 correct
Caption: and it might be influenced by the
Caption: situation in which you took the test but
Caption: it can help guide you to understand
Caption: yourself a little bit more
Caption: so one that I've taken in the past that
Caption: I found useful was called the disc
Caption: Theory so this separates your
Caption: personality into four trait and you get
Caption: a report that shows how you might act in
Caption: certain situations whether that's when
Caption: there's a conflict arising or you're
Caption: faced with a challenge or you're doing
Caption: something you really enjoy
Caption: and breaks it down into four categories
Caption: first is more dominant which is someone
Caption: who's more results oriented
Caption: strong-willed or often Direct
Caption: is the influence being more optimistic
Caption: Lively enthusiastic than steadiness
Caption: which is even tempered patient and
Caption: tactful and then
Caption: conscientiousness of trouble saying that
Caption: word a bit more analytical and semantic
Caption: as well
Caption: and it's looking at really how you
Caption: prefer to focus in on the world how you
Caption: process information and react in
Caption: different scenarios
Caption: and these Frameworks really just give
Caption: you a better understanding of yourself
Caption: but can also help you understand those
Caption: around you so if you do these tests with
Caption: some of your team members and then
Caption: compare the results it can really help
Caption: you to understand how you can work
Caption: better together
Caption: at a situation where I had a colleague
Caption: who was in a similar position of mine
Caption: and we're often working together but
Caption: constantly butting heads I had a hard
Caption: time communicating with her and really
Caption: just you know underst difficulty
Caption: understanding her approach to different
Caption: situations
Caption: but we took this test and compared our
Caption: results and she was super high on the D
Caption: side the D and C side and I was really
Caption: high on the S and I side so completely
Caption: opposite scales of the spectrum
Caption: but because of this I was able to
Caption: understand her a little bit better and
Caption: that allowed me to then adjust my
Caption: Approach when I was working with her and
Caption: understand a bit more when she was
Caption: communicating with me in a way that I
Caption: naturally did not enjoy as much so it
Caption: helped us work better together in the
Caption: end
Caption: along with understanding our personality
Caption: type we can help to understand our
Caption: leadership styles and look at developing
Caption: different types of leadership styles and
Caption: adjusting them depending on our
Caption: situation with our organization
Caption: this is called the full range Leadership
Caption: Model and it's really dividing into uh
Caption: four or three types one that's lit
Caption: across to subcategories and the first
Caption: leadership type is What's called the
Caption: laissez-faire and this is really giving
Caption: the empowerment to your team members and
Caption: those around you this is letting them
Caption: make the decisions and really empowering
Caption: them so it's the the least sort of
Caption: Hands-On and it's really good if your
Caption: team is really highly skilled and highly
Caption: experienced and trustworthy to reach
Caption: that goal really empowering them to be
Caption: the leaders themselves
Caption: the next is the transactional leadership
Caption: which is more about motivating through a
Caption: system of rewards and and maybe
Caption: punishments
Caption: um and that's broken into categories of
Caption: where management only steps in uh if the
Caption: team isn't doing well otherwise lets
Caption: them keep going and giving them rewards
Caption: and the other is focused on that reward
Caption: of the objectives
Caption: this is good if your organization is
Caption: really wanting to standardize practices
Caption: and developing at on a journey of
Caption: becoming a highly effective operating
Caption: team
Caption: and it yeah it's helpful it helps for
Caption: standardizing those practices the the
Caption: last type is the transformational
Caption: leadership this is about really being
Caption: that inspirational motivation Visionary
Caption: role model that people look for and has
Caption: been proven to be the most effective
Caption: uh it has more of a humanitarian
Caption: approach and it's really underpinned by
Caption: self-awareness as well
Caption: so these different types you can have
Caption: different styles and you can also adapt
Caption: and change your style it's important to
Caption: get an understanding of how do you like
Caption: to lead others
Caption: we can also look to develop our
Caption: leadership skills such as communication
Caption: research has found that communication is
Caption: Central to leadership
Caption: internal Communication in an
Caption: organization can significantly increase
Caption: a someone's your team's productivity
Caption: and there is also a theory that
Caption: communication and a message is seven
Caption: percent
Caption: verbal 38 tone in expression and 55 body
Caption: language
Caption: so there is a bit of a debate on the
Caption: exact percentages that everything goes
Caption: across but there's a general
Caption: understanding that 70 to 90 percent of
Caption: communication is non-verbal so that
Caption: means it's really important for us to
Caption: think about how we're delivering
Caption: messages to our teammates are you just
Caption: sending an email with an important team
Caption: update or are you putting out a video or
Caption: maybe jumping on a video call and a chat
Caption: think about how you like to be
Caption: communicated to as well
Caption: do you like to have all of the
Caption: information up front before a meeting or
Caption: do you like to just have a short quick
Caption: summary and understand that and
Caption: communicate it back to your team which
Caption: means they will in turn work better with
Caption: you
Caption: especially now that we're in you know
Caption: pretty much a lot of remote based
Caption: working situations that communication is
Caption: very important and using all the
Caption: different tools that we have to keep our
Caption: communication styles from just being
Caption: verbal and using those tone and
Caption: expressions as well using all of the
Caption: gifts and little icons slack reacts
Caption: whatever it may be to show your emotion
Caption: throughout your communication
Caption: this can help you connect better with
Caption: your friends colleagues and your team
Caption: members and really become an effective
Caption: leader that has that strong
Caption: communication
Caption: for me the next most important
Caption: leadership skill that's underpinned by
Caption: self-awareness is emotional intelligence
Caption: this is sometimes referred to as EQ
Caption: and the first thing that is essential
Caption: for any degree of emotional intelligence
Caption: is that self-awareness and understanding
Caption: of herself
Caption: because emotional intelligence is all
Caption: about being able to recognize our
Caption: emotions to understand the merchants
Caption: that we may be feeling but also how we
Caption: react when we're feeling these emotions
Caption: and the next step is then being able to
Caption: control those emotions in those
Caption: situations
Caption: so there are four components of
Caption: emotional intelligence the first is
Caption: self-awareness so self-awareness is a
Caption: sub-category of emotional intelligence
Caption: but it's really focused on the
Caption: self-awareness of your emotions are you
Caption: feeling happy anxious angry scared
Caption: excited what emotion are you feeling
Caption: the next is the self-management so
Caption: that's being able to then control those
Caption: emotions especially in a workplace
Caption: organization if there's something that
Caption: makes you angry you don't want to lash
Caption: out and create a negative situation you
Caption: want to be able to control those you
Caption: also need to be able to adapt when
Caption: things are changing and to have a
Caption: positive outlook on things that are
Caption: happening as well
Caption: the next step is that social awareness
Caption: so really being empathetic to those
Caption: around you and to the team you can break
Caption: empathy down into three parts the first
Caption: is cognitive which is all about I know
Caption: how you think the next is emotional I
Caption: know how you feel
Caption: and the next is empathetic concern which
Caption: is I care about you
Caption: and great leaders are those that can
Caption: really be empathetic to you in those
Caption: different situations we talked about
Caption: being understanding being supportive
Caption: especially in times like through covid
Caption: we have you know our kids that we're
Caption: looking after or we have family members
Caption: that might be unwell it's really
Caption: important to have empathetic and
Caption: emotionally intelligent leaders
Caption: and in turn this also is important for
Caption: organizational awareness if something
Caption: negative is happening with your
Caption: organization or your team is
Caption: collectively experienced some sort of
Caption: emotion being aware of that and then
Caption: also being aware of how you can help
Caption: address it and how you can manage those
Caption: emotions in the team by being an
Caption: influencer by being a coach or a mentor
Caption: and helping other people then in turn
Caption: manage their emotions being a diffuser
Caption: in certain situations or helping to
Caption: uplift your team when things might not
Caption: be going so well
Caption: so harnessing these emotions can really
Caption: help us to achieve our goal and it's all
Caption: underpinned by that self-awareness
Caption: so emotional intelligence is super
Caption: important as we said we want people who
Caption: are more empathetic who are more
Caption: understanding and can really relate to
Caption: us in different situations
Caption: we need to make sure that there is some
Caption: sort of work-life balance there are
Caption: people
Caption: and that we can handle change because
Caption: we're in a very rapidly changing type of
Caption: environment especially in Tech
Caption: so people with high emotional
Caption: intelligence are naturally curious and
Caption: they're not afraid to ask questions
Caption: they're able to empathize with their
Caption: teammates around them put themselves in
Caption: the shoes of others and really diffuse
Caption: any sort of situation when you're
Caption: emotionally intelligent it'll help your
Caption: team members be emotionally intelligent
Caption: too to come to you when they need that
Caption: support or when they have things that
Caption: they're uncertain about because they
Caption: know that you will be there to help them
Caption: make it through and you'll be able to
Caption: make those really strong connections
Caption: really influence and become that great
Caption: leader
Caption: so how can you increase your emotional
Caption: intelligence well one way to do this is
Caption: just by starting to write a list of all
Caption: the different emotions that you know and
Caption: that you know how to feel
Caption: expanding your emotional vocabulary can
Caption: really help you with then in turn
Caption: identifying your emotions
Caption: go out and research different types of
Caption: emotions and see if you're able to
Caption: identify them and yourselves so just
Caption: being able to put a name to it can help
Caption: you to be more emotionally intelligent
Caption: and then take the time to observe
Caption: however you're reacting in different
Caption: situations especially if things maybe
Caption: didn't go so well maybe there was
Caption: something that made you really
Caption: frustrated and you ended up reacting
Caption: negatively take a step back to reflect
Caption: and think about how you could have
Caption: handled that situation differently what
Caption: was it that triggered that emotion and
Caption: how can you prevent that negative
Caption: reaction in the future
Caption: but also understand that people around
Caption: you and your team members will react
Caption: differently to different situations as
Caption: well everyone's definition of hard is
Caption: different so even though someone might
Caption: be struggling with it try to take a
Caption: moment to put yourself in their shoes
Caption: and understand how they might be feeling
Caption: before you send off that angry email
Caption: take a step back and reflect and revisit
Caption: with a new mindset to make sure you're
Caption: approaching the problem positively
Caption: be diplomatic especially in a workplace
Caption: environment and keep things emotion free
Caption: and be able to really ground yourself in
Caption: that self-awareness and keep a steady
Caption: head especially as a leader for your
Caption: team keeping a steady head when things
Caption: might not be going well can help Inspire
Caption: your team to keep moving forward as well
Caption: another aspect and important trait to
Caption: being a great leader is something that's
Caption: called self leadership and this is
Caption: really just the process of influencing
Caption: yourself to achieve your goals if you
Caption: focus on influencing yourself it'll
Caption: naturally leak out to those around you
Caption: and you'll start to be an influencer in
Caption: Inspiration a role model for others
Caption: around you
Caption: you don't always have a great leader
Caption: that's going to be giving you all these
Caption: opportunities and pushing you to the
Caption: front so being a leader for yourself is
Caption: very important
Caption: and you can influence yourself using a
Caption: few different key strategies the first
Caption: is through your behavior doing that
Caption: self-reflection self-observation setting
Caption: some goals for yourself and really
Caption: tracking how you're going towards it and
Caption: reflecting on how you may be going
Caption: looking at different cues in little
Caption: idiosyncrasies that you have becoming
Caption: aware of yours strengths and weaknesses
Caption: and what you need to work on the next is
Caption: through natural reward building pleasure
Caption: and enjoyable features into your work
Caption: can really help you be more driven to
Caption: continue achieving those goals and work
Caption: harder
Caption: and then it's constructive thought
Caption: patterns evaluating your beliefs and in
Caption: assumptions but with a positive mindset
Caption: practicing that positive self-talk
Caption: especially if you're one who might be
Caption: suffering from something like imposter
Caption: syndrome where you're naturally you know
Caption: holding yourself back practicing that
Caption: positive self-talk and reminding you
Caption: yourself that you can do it can help you
Caption: to be a great leader
Caption: so taking together these strategies can
Caption: help you define
Caption: your gain your self-awareness and belief
Caption: that you are constantly working towards
Caption: the goal realizing your goal
Caption: um recognize rationalize and reflect
Caption: think about how you're acting in
Caption: different ways and really work on
Caption: yourself and that'll naturally flow out
Caption: to the team members around you
Caption: there's also something called
Caption: self-efficacy this is an individual's
Caption: belief in their capabilities to execute
Caption: their behaviors so really it's the
Caption: belief in your own ability to succeed
Caption: and this is another thing without
Caption: positive self-talk and the
Caption: self-reflection can help you to motivate
Caption: yourself
Caption: uh if you are believing in yourself
Caption: you're more likely to take on challenges
Caption: and be better in difficult situations
Caption: and your team members can see that as an
Caption: inspiration and role model see how
Caption: you've handled those negative situations
Caption: see how you're able to continue to keep
Caption: moving forward and believe that yourself
Caption: and your team can reach that goal
Caption: you can develop self-efficacy through
Caption: experience by seeing those people and
Caption: supporting other people around you so
Caption: show the support to your team members as
Caption: well and it'll help them develop their
Caption: self-efficacy so working on all these
Caption: skills can make us more confident
Caption: stronger leaders
Caption: so in turn our benefit our followers who
Caption: are following us will then benefit from
Caption: all these different skills that we've
Caption: been working on within ourselves in our
Caption: awareness of ourself
Caption: the followers are very important because
Caption: they're the ones who made us leaders in
Caption: the first place
Caption: they look up to us and they really rely
Caption: on us to to help them succeed as well so
Caption: share your knowledge encourage your team
Caption: to reflect any of those things that
Caption: you're learning about yourself share
Caption: with your teams so that they can then in
Caption: turn understand and maybe reflect on how
Caption: they act in certain situations as well
Caption: make sure you coach and instead of just
Caption: giving people the answers I had a
Caption: colleague who would always just answer
Caption: any of my questions with a question when
Caption: I asked him for advice
Caption: I would come up to him and say hey
Caption: should I apply for this raila leadership
Caption: camp and you'd be like well what do you
Caption: think and say okay uh well I think it'd
Caption: be fine I think it'd be a good
Caption: experience well why do you think that
Caption: and it would just keep going on and on
Caption: to where eventually I would then just
Caption: answer my own question but it also
Caption: encouraged that introspection in self
Caption: reflection which made me also understand
Caption: what was really valuable to me and make
Caption: sure that I was creating these goals for
Caption: myself and moving myself forward
Caption: so those those different techniques that
Caption: you can do to help Inspire your
Caption: followers but that's one that I always
Caption: enjoy
Caption: and also there's actually a study that
Caption: was published just last year that proves
Caption: that your followers will benefit from
Caption: your leadership of your a Leader's
Caption: self-awareness so if a leader has strong
Caption: self-awareness this will naturally lead
Caption: to followers being self-leaders because
Caption: they'll see the guidance and inspiration
Caption: from those leaders around them where the
Caption: leaders are you're talking about goal
Caption: setting and these kind of things like
Caption: that a follower will then start to set
Caption: these goals for themselves and drive
Caption: themselves forward
Caption: in turn that will make the leader more
Caption: confident they'll have greater
Caption: self-efficacy and they'll continue to be
Caption: better leaders and reflect that back to
Caption: their followers
Caption: and they also found that this continues
Caption: on so that their followers are then more
Caption: likely to become leaders themselves they
Caption: see the role models and the actions that
Caption: you're doing as a leader and they become
Caption: they're more likely to become a leader
Caption: and they're also more likely to be
Caption: nominated for a promotion more
Caption: successful in their career so through
Caption: working through your self-awareness your
Caption: team and your colleagues and people
Caption: around you will become better leaders as
Caption: well
Caption: and not only will your team become
Caption: better leaders but your organization and
Caption: the company that you're working for will
Caption: benefit from this as well and research
Caption: research has demonstrated that
Caption: leadership behavior is really influenced
Caption: the overall performance of a company
Caption: workers are more trusting as software
Caption: leaders because those leaders are are
Caption: empathetic they're people that we can
Caption: approach their problems we can be open
Caption: about when things are going wrong we can
Caption: talk about you know failures and but
Caption: look at them in a positive light and
Caption: learn from it and move forward
Caption: Maya Angelou said I've learned that
Caption: people will forget what you said people
Caption: will forget what you did but people will
Caption: never forget how you made them feel
Caption: self-awire leaders and teammates can
Caption: really make an impact and be more
Caption: engaged in their work and in the end
Caption: produce better results
Caption: so we can build self-awareness first by
Caption: understanding ourselves practicing and
Caption: re-evaluating ourselves in the context
Caption: of others using different tools to learn
Caption: about how we approach different
Caption: situations what are our natural
Caption: personality types what are our strengths
Caption: and weaknesses what are some areas that
Caption: we need to work on and when do we need
Caption: to rely on others
Caption: they actually found that people
Caption: can build self-awareness by putting
Caption: themselves in situations where their
Caption: focus is naturally drawn inward they did
Caption: this by putting people in front of Amir
Caption: and recording them and recording their
Caption: actions and then having them watch
Caption: themselves back
Caption: so as as much as a lot of us hate
Caption: watching ourselves this really helps us
Caption: to become self-aware whenever I do a
Caption: presentation I always go back and watch
Caption: the recording because that helps me
Caption: learn the things that I need to work on
Caption: and things that I can improve for next
Caption: time so put yourself in those situations
Caption: where you're being drawn to your
Caption: yourself and you're seeing thinking
Caption: about or understanding how you've acted
Caption: in different situations to help build
Caption: that self-awareness
Caption: there's also things called
Caption: self-awareness triggers which are
Caption: usually some big events that happen in
Caption: our life they really make us reflect and
Caption: understand a bit of ourselves on a
Caption: deeper level but these are only really
Caption: beneficial to helping our self-awareness
Caption: if we take that time to reflect to think
Caption: about how did we react in that situation
Caption: how did we handle that how could what
Caption: could we have done differently change
Caption: those questions from why to what take
Caption: those tests talk to the people around
Caption: you you get that feedback from your
Caption: teammates as well to help build that
Caption: external self-awareness and understand
Caption: how you are perceived by others and
Caption: those around you
Caption: do you need to work more on your
Caption: mindfulness do you need to build up that
Caption: emotional intelligence do you need to
Caption: sort of control your emotions in
Caption: different situations what are you really
Caption: good at maybe how do you need to alter
Caption: your communication for certain team
Caption: members
Caption: take a step back slow down your emotions
Caption: boil and practice that self-regulation
Caption: so in summary we learned about
Caption: leadership and that anyone can be a
Caption: leader we can all build up our
Caption: self-awareness and that can drive us to
Caption: become better leaders and in turn our
Caption: followers and our teammates and those
Caption: people around us are more likely to
Caption: become leaders as well
Caption: we learned how self-awareness can be
Caption: negative if we don't think about it in
Caption: the right aspect
Caption: so we need and we don't focus on both
Caption: the internal and external so we need to
Caption: to balance those two sides and practice
Caption: that positive self-talk change our
Caption: questions from why to what and look at
Caption: how we can learn and move forward
Caption: we heard how self-awareness can be
Caption: beneficial to ourselves our team and our
Caption: organization so through self-awareness
Caption: you can be a great leader
Caption: and I'll leave you with his quote
Caption: at the center of your being you have the
Caption: answer you know who you are and you know
Caption: what you want
Caption: so thank you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: and if you scan the QR code on the
Caption: screen or go to the bitly link you can
Caption: get access to all of my resources that I
Caption: used in The Talk today as well as my
Caption: slides and everything as well
Caption: around
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hello great talk Melissa
Caption: um so you mentioned failures and looking
Caption: at them in a positive light do you have
Caption: any recent examples of situations you've
Caption: done that
Caption: so looking at things in a positive
Caption: flight
Caption: yeah
Caption: um
Caption: yeah well so for example you know I so
Caption: living in Melbourne
Caption: um in the pandemic we had you know
Caption: really intense lockdowns that were you
Caption: know quite difficult to work with
Caption: um and so there was a lot of negative
Caption: emotions and negative things happening
Caption: with
Caption: um the lockdowns and it was a struggle
Caption: to to manage
Caption: um during that scenario but on I try to
Caption: reflect on it in a positive light on the
Caption: things that I was able to achieve over
Caption: that time so even though you know it was
Caption: a a really difficult time in my life I
Caption: was able to focus on things like
Caption: practicing public speaking and doing
Caption: virtual talks and learning more about
Caption: myself and doing more of that
Caption: self-reflection and everything as well
Caption: so instead of focusing on sort of the
Caption: negative things of being stuck in your
Caption: house nothing to see people I focused on
Caption: the things that I was able to achieve
Caption: despite
Caption: um you know being in a situation even if
Caption: it wasn't every day that I was able to
Caption: you know be super productive there's
Caption: definitely a lot of days that were spent
Caption: you know just sitting on the couch being
Caption: a bit miserable focusing on the days
Caption: that were positive where I was able to
Caption: achieve something despite the situation
Caption: I you told about one of your colleagues
Caption: or one of your maybe one of your
Caption: colleagues where your colleague was uh
Caption: kind of more dominating in in her
Caption: personality so how did you get get about
Caption: it get around it because you did tell
Caption: that you did some certain strategies
Caption: around it but in that situation what
Caption: kind of strategies did you use because
Caption: that was something which didn't you
Caption: didn't elaborate on it yep yeah so the
Caption: the colleague was a bit more dominating
Caption: and indirects whereas I'm naturally
Caption: um a bit more I I guess
Caption: um yeah sort of Less Direct in my
Caption: approach to things
Caption: um so I well part of it was when I was
Caption: communicating with her I made sure that
Caption: I was very direct and straight to the
Caption: point
Caption: um so that she would understand the
Caption: message that I was getting across and
Caption: when it came to her Communications with
Caption: me I would often especially if it was
Caption: something I would say email or would not
Caption: do that strategy of instead of doing my
Caption: initial reaction which was often take
Caption: quite taken aback because
Caption: um because it was often quite forceful
Caption: what she was saying I would just pause
Caption: and think about it for a second and try
Caption: to think about the message that she
Caption: probably was actually trying to convey
Caption: really giving her the benefit of the
Caption: doubt that she probably wasn't trying to
Caption: be mean or aggressive she was just
Caption: trying to be direct in her message and
Caption: get the information across so it's part
Caption: of putting yourself in the other
Caption: person's shoes and taking a step back
Caption: and then also trying to even replicate
Caption: their ways of communicating or their
Caption: actions when you're working with them so
Caption: that they're more receptive to the
Caption: things that you're describing and also
Caption: she took the test as well so she was
Caption: also more than aware of my personality
Caption: and my traits which helped the way she
Caption: was working with me it made it so that
Caption: she was Less Direct because she realized
Caption: that it wasn't really the the way that I
Caption: like to communicate or work myself
Caption: three minutes I can probably do one more
Caption: time yeah
Caption: um thank you my name's Cecily that was
Caption: an amazing presentation
Caption: um as a super self-aware perfect leader
Caption: um how do I help
Caption: um other leaders who are trying to get
Caption: me to follow but they're not
Caption: particularly self-aware is there any way
Caption: to inspire up when you can't be like hey
Caption: do a personality test
Caption: yeah
Caption: um well feedback is is very very
Caption: powerful tool um you know a lot of
Caption: people yeah they might just not be aware
Caption: of what they're doing that you know they
Caption: might not be aware that what they're
Caption: saying is you know putting people in a
Caption: bad mood or that it's you know really
Caption: not helping the team so just giving that
Caption: feedback to them and having it be like
Caption: an open conversation of you know saying
Caption: um in in this situation this is you know
Caption: the the outcomes of what happened how do
Caption: you think about that and giving them the
Caption: opportunity to reflect themselves so
Caption: saying you know how do you think the
Caption: team reacted in that situation and
Caption: letting them you know have the space
Caption: through your questions like my colleague
Caption: who is always saying why why do you want
Caption: to do that um getting them almost
Caption: forcing them to reflect as well
Caption: yeah
Caption: okay I think that's all we have time for
Caption: thank you so much Melissa thanks
Caption: everyone
Caption: [Applause]